los destrozos provocados por los
disturbios del jueves son visibles en
todas las calles de Dakar la capital
vehículos y neumáticos quemados calles
llenas de piedras en la universidad de
la capital se quemaron varios edificios
provocando cuantosos daños la
universidad está cerrada hasta nuevo
aviso y los estudiantes están huyendo
del Campus con sus pertenencias en los
barrios los habitantes están muy
preocupados en muchas localidades por la
tarde los jóvenes comenzaron a bloquear
las calles este viernes podría ser otro
día a riesgo para senegal los
simpatizantes
con los que hemos hablado aseguran que
seguían movilizándose para defender a su
líder el gobierno por su parte asegura
que hará lo necesario para mantener el